l'enfance pour vous c'est aussi
peut-être le jardinage ça va être le
sujet essentiel l'un des sujets
essentiels de cette émission et je vais
tout de suite qu on vous retrouve non
pas dans ce studio mais mais chez vous
dans votre jardin dans en train de vous
occuper des plantes et aussi des légumes
alors cessé chez vous c'est tabou dans
ce qu'une équipe d'antenne de quitter
les bouches mais ira promis nous
retrouvons daniel gélin rockeuse dans le
dialogue avec avec la terre avec avec le
rythme des saisons ce finalement
montbray rythme c'est le rythme des
saisons c'est le rythme d'un comédien
non il ya justement une des ordres enfin
hiatus dans cette histoire mais par
exemple lorsque je me trouve dans une
cité quelconque entendu d'une pièce de
théâtre en tournée ou même à paris
lorsque par exemple il pleut moi je me
dis c'est bon pour mon jardin il ya
longtemps qu'il n'a pas plu c'est bon
ton le gazon c'est bon pour les légumes
c'est bon pour les arbres que cultiver
vous ont le plus de choses possible
enfin ce que l'exposition du jardin ce
que le climat d'eure-et-loir et c'est
que
la qualité du terrain me permet je te
dire à peu près ce qu est ce que vous
vous considérez comme un vrai jardinier
non pas du tout je suis est vraiment un
jardinier amateur mais je pense que si
une certaine partie de ma vie est à
refaire je ferais c'est d'une façon pas
scientifiquement fin je me mettrais un
peu plus sérieusement et que de toute
façon passionnelle ah oui mais même plus
que mentionné stationné à c'est une
chose d'instinctif jeu sans ça je devine
les choses je devine je sens quand les
plantes ont soif de sang j'ai les doigts
verts c'est certain j'ai une espèce de
de sensation presque parce que sensuelle
avec tous parler ou plantes
pourquoi par les nombreux m arrive de
soliloquer certainement mais il s'
établir un contact il y a il y aller les
mauvaises herbes qui sont ici sont âpres
que jean gueule que j'assume et puis il
ya d'autres qui viennent facilement
comme ça vous les doigts des guerres
celle là j'ai tendance à les laisser en
place parce que je suis pas du tout pour
le jardin à la française bien bien
disciplinés et vous avez cessé plante là
qui sont molles qui sont tendres avec
lesquels j'ai des rapports de tendresse
vous avez la même chose avec avec les
arbres quand vous tailler les arbres il
ya il ya une espèce de forme de dialogue
c'est certain vous avez un potager aussi
rapidement le potager c'est c'est très
important on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
avoir deux
on ne peut pas s'estimer vraiment
jardinier si on n'a pas trop sage et je
crois que les gens les gens ressemblent
à leur jardin ou leur jardin fini par
leur semble évidemment lié à un peu
désordre mais je suis moi même un petit
peu désordonné il il ya un côté bohème
échevelé ac c'est un petit peu ce jardin
me ressemble mais c'est peut-être ça qui
m'a plu lorsque j'ai acheté il avait
déjà cet aspect là et je continue à à
conserver ce côté un petit peu sauvage
naturel un petit peu comme si c'était
lui même qui se construisait peu à peu
comme ça avec les saisons avec le soleil
avec les pluies avec le temps
en gardant ce reportage ces images ce
n'est pas un jardin vous avez une
véritable exploitation agricole pourra
du tout les le maïs c'était le mile
style voisins on sait pas votre
champagne ont alors utilisé un mois non